Do you hear "Yanni"?
Mother of "Laurel"?
A recent poll found that 47% of the people hear "Yanni" while 53% hear "Laurel"
It is clear that this created controversy in the Internet which led to the division of the nation
So what is science behind madness?
One of the first aspects is setup
If you play this section without providing the option "Yani" or "Laurel"
You may not have heard any of these words
But by reading them, you are preparing to hear one or the other.
Second, when you talk, you produce sound waves that spread through the air
This is a visual recording of sound waves to record the original Yani / Laurel
Created by Brad Stewart, Professor of Speech, Language and Hearing
Here is his portrayal of saying "Laurel"
You can see that the audio characteristics are very similar
Here is a depiction of him saying "Yani"
The audio features are also similar
So, the words "Yani" and "Laurel" are more vocal than you think
Whether you're listening to a laptop, phone or headphones
It will affect what you hear based on the sound quality
But what if you listen through the same device but you hear different things with someone beside you
This may be related to the age of your ears
Sounds in "Yani" play on the highest frequency of the votes in "Laurel"
As we get older, our ears are less able to hear higher frequencies
If you hear "yani", you may have younger ears
Luckily with the help of the Internet, we can hear both
The wonderful Twitter user posted "xxv @" cut to the sound tone brought down and up
When you hear it low 30%, you will hear "Yanni"
Yani 2x
But when you hear her with a 30% higher note, you are likely to hear "Laurel"
Laurel 2x
Your brain has a lot of stimulation at all times, using existing information and subtle neural pathways to focus its attention
This is why in a noisy party you can listen to your friend by your side
But pay close attention to another conversation if necessary
Similarly, your brain unconsciously chooses any frequencies in the recording to notice it
So ... what is the final answer?
If you hear "Laurel", you are right! The original recording is Laurel's saying
But with higher frequencies added, create ambiguity
You love learning about amazing and interesting things in the world?
In fact, we just started a new podcast called "SIDENOTE"
Where we explore things that hinder us or make us curious in life
Then enter all the sciences that raise the mind behind them
We are happy to check it out on iTunes or any podcast application you use
Your support means a lot to us as we slowly embark on a journey to explore more science in a new way
Again it is called SIDENOTE which is new, so we are excited to know what you think
We'll leave some links below
Subscribe to more weekly science videos every Thursday translated by angel: girl